Here we have a rectangle,
which is 5/9 from the meter
and is 7/8 meters wide.
How is his face?
I recommend that you stop the video
and think about it.
One way to think about it
is to say our face
will be equal to the width of the height.
We will simply multiply these two sizes.
The width is 7/8 meters.
This will be equal to 7/8 meters,
multiplied by height,
which is 5/9 from the meter.
5/9 from the meter.
How will this be equal?
It will be a meter
per meter, which gives us a square meter, means a square meter.
We can record it like that.
Then we will have
7, it will be in another color,
I will have 7 by 5 in the numerator,
which gives us 35, and in the denominator
we will have 8 at 9,
which makes 72.
And we're ready.
This is the face of this rectangle.
35/72 per square meter.
What I want to do is think more deeply
why this is true.
Or else to think about it.
To do so,
will divide this area
of the same rectangles.
We see that on the horizontal we have 7,
in the horizontal direction we have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7 or you can say that each row has 7
such rectangles.
In each column we have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
You see we have 5 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7.
We have 5 7 of these rectangles.
So we have 35 rectangles.
I'll record this, 35 rectangles.
What is the face of each of these rectangles?
The width is 7/8 meters,
and is divided into 7 equal parts
in the horizontal direction, this means that each one
is exactly 1 / 8th of a meter wide.
By the same logic,
if the total is 5/9,
and the height of each is 1/5,
because we have 5 rectangles in a column,
then the height of everyone will be
1/9 of the meter.
What is the face of this part here?
This will be equal to 1/9 of the meter
1/8 meter.
The face here will be
1/9 of the meter 1/8 meter,
which is equal to 1 by 1 equal to 1,
9 by 8 is 72 and a meter by meter
is a square meter.
Then face each of these 35 rectangles
is 1/72 of the square meter.
If I take 35, then the common face of all of them
will be 35 in the area of ​​each.
35 by 1/72 of the square meter.
How will this be equal?
That's exactly what we got here.
35 per 1/72 of the square meter will be
35/72 of the square meter.
And this 35 is the same as what I got in yellow.
Here it is.
You can multiply by 5/9
7/8 to get this.
But I hope that when you think about the person
of each of these rectangles,
you can find a clearer explanation
where this number comes from.